[Music]
this next award goes to one audience
member who didn't like the movie Sully -
the one audience member didn't like the
movie silly and then I&C goes to the
person in seat 13 eh let's see what
their problem okay
I've died recall eagles were not
involved yeah I think that's supposed to
be a seagull but it doesn't really know
that is quite clearly an American Eagle
I bet you down at the costume shop they
go no I swear to god that's that's a
Sikh oh yeah I'll be 400 bucks yeah they
put on the Cornucopia angles got
different eyes yeah that's a that's a oh
my god oh look toll had enough tolls off
to beat the [ __ ] out of a bird costume
guy like that they told me it was a
seagull oh wait wasn't the Sully about
geese anyway yep it was about geese
apparently though this conspiracy
theorists who think it was a giant flock
of American Bald Eagles I think they're
trying to just say Birds stick up for
each other that's it yours are all real
tight with each other they like mammals
yeah now somewhat accused these writers
of being lazy and having the old Monday
morning blues but not me see
[Music]
you